the snowy back roads of eastern ukraine
lead to the front lines of this ongoing
war between the national army and
russian-backed separatists
they get to the front in a converted and
battered old ambulance this isn't a
high-tech army
our journey took us through the heavily
mined countryside the red signs warn of
the danger of leaving the road
the separatists positions run parallel
to us all the way
we're with the 24th battalion of the
ukrainian army they're taking us to a
village closed to the outside world
only 11 of the original 200 inhabitants
remain
it's not near the front line it is
actually the front line
and there's fighting here all the time
[Music]
the shooting is virtually constant
some major rounds being exchanged as
well
that's what it's like for the villagers
who live here
every single day
listening to this
shooting
this
wall has been going on for years now
and it's not reported much but it's
still fighting every day
after eight years at the center of this
war there's not much left of nova
alexandrovka
the houses are battered and largely
empty
the soldiers say that most of those who
remain stay indoors particularly in
winter
but 73 year old helena welcomed us
inside
she told us how all of her windows were
smashed by bombs during the worst
fighting
it is so bad at times she lies next to
her brick oven for protection
clutching her important documents
prepare to run if she has to
there's no electricity no shops or
medical services
but she's got nowhere to go
more importantly she doesn't want to go
to put it simply helena is tougher than
all of us
now
from their overwatch positions on the
roofs of houses in the village the
soldiers keep a continuous eye on the
separatist positions about a hundred
meters away
they say they've been at war for eight
years already
and rarely if ever discuss a russian
invasion
although they accept it could happen
with
along a 250 mile demarcation line the
two sides day and night exchange fire
from their trenches
beneath ground the job of preparing for
fighting never stops
a bloody eight-year conflict that could
be about to get even worse
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine